christmas is here mulled wine is a real
Christmas classic but I'm going to give
it a modern 21st century twist first
pour red wine into a pan and gently heat
now I'm gonna make a fragrant bouquet
garni basically a really nice aromatic
teabag muslin cloth absolutely perfect
for this if you havenõt muslin cloth a
brand new Japheth is just as good now
first off cardamom pods they incredib
aromatic and more importantly gives it a
really nice dense spicy flavor next add
a pinch of clothes clothes are dried
flower buds and had a lovely pungent
sweet flavour then drop in a couple of
star anis which adds an anise seed note
a cinnamon stick cinnamon sticks are
made from the bark of trees native to
sri lanka break one in and this gives a
warm sweet spice to the wine lemongrass
this makes it slightly Asian II a little
bit more sort of exciting but gives a
really nice light twist to the wine
normal to do first is just press down on
the lemongrass and what that does it
starts to release all that oil and
flavor once it's crushed
just cut it over the muslin cloth
once all your spices are in followed
muslin cloth and tie timely I know
that is like a little mr. perfect chefs
pillow into the wine next add orange
zest twist then cut the orange into
wedges and pop those into
to sweeten the wine put in a tablespoon
of Demerara sugar
next stem ginger gives them more wine a
little bit of a sort of kick almost like
that really nice sort of ginger beer
aftertaste on the back your throat
finally a couple of tablespoons of the
ginger syrup and then simply heat the
wine gently for four to five minutes to
infuse all the fantastic flavors but
don't let it boil or the alcohol will
evaporate and the earth the most amazing
spice nuts
I love nuts so I'm using Brazil's
almonds walnuts and hazelnuts and then
finally pistachios lovely very nice
festive mix as a nurse toast they start
to release their natural oils then add a
couple of pinches of salt
and then just let them lightly toast
once the nuts start to color at half a
teaspoon of cayenne pepper which is made
from ground chilies then sprinkle in
half a teaspoon of paprika a milder
spice made from dried pimentos for
sweetness and doubt
[Music]
and now you can see the nuts absorbing
all that wonderful flavor
delicious finally put in a sprig of
rosemary give the pan a good toss to
make sure all the nuts are thoroughly
coated and they're done
[Applause]
[Music]